camera action roll you are about to
embark on your biggest manhunt ever
answer bounty ever what can you tell me
about it this guy's watching me when a
rabbit goes out of his hole he looks up
for the hawk and then he stops any
weights and there's no hot sand he runs
to the little thing or his little carrot
and he's always watching for that hawk
this guy is the rabbit and I am the hawk
he's watching everywhere any look he had
a dream the other day and he called his
girlfriend and said I had a dream they
surrounded my house Wow oh you're not in
a hotel huh
and he said come on out brought out with
your hands in the air you know who that
he was it was the hawk well I mean the
dog so he's this is good no this is so
good
too bad I can't take you guys on a
ride-along I mean I'll be unbelievable
because it's called dog it's up to me
who I choose to be the most wanted this
is the biggest bond I've ever chased
he says he's got two guns and all the
bullets have my name on him and this is
the last bond that Beth wrote and she
trusted the guy to write the bond he'd
get out and pay later as soon as he got
out of jail he bolted and she was very
sick at that time so I couldn't go right
after him right then so this is you know
like I say this one's for Beth and I'm
so it's eight months almost nine months
now I'm very emotional and I told my
manager Amy the tears have turned to
blood and wait till they get a load of
dog without Beth because now there's a
purpose there is a real purpose I don't
want to die tomorrow but I'm not afraid
to I won't get in front of a train and
go hit me but the fear is gone I've
never left a note to my children and I
left him a note this time just a case so
this is real this is this one here do
I know I'm not saying you're I'm not
saying that there's fear but there's a
lot of danger involved and when you face
danger like this
are you or do you worry well cuz this
guy wants you as much as you want him
yes
I'm concerned but I have an angel drone
in the sky that I'm gonna make her proud
where she could say that's my big daddy
dear God hope that God the cameras are
rolling when I catch him this one is
extra special this will be all for bad
if this one's for Beth like I say the
cameras if they weren't rolling I'd hit
him in the mouth or something but
because of God and the cameras in the
law I can't but I'm fully loaded in
previous shows we chased bond jumpers
somebody out on bail this one were
chasing fugitives
how have you been tracking him and how
hard is it to track a guy like that and
find him because you somehow always
managed to find these guys well this guy
is very very very difficult leaves no
this guy I'm going for the supernatural
this guy I'm in prayer over this guy is
good the one that listen I've arrested
eight thousand fugitives in 41 years
this is the best I've ever chased after
what's his crime he has drug dealing and
there's some other things I don't want
to say on television this guy may not go
to heaven let me just say like that this
guy's got a lot of payin to do he's a
real-life bad guy he is getting life
this guy ain't getting out this guy's
done they give him life and a day that
means you die your your body sits in the
cell for 24 hours and then they take you
out no this is this guy's gone this is
it when he sees my face that's it right
there
I don't want you to give away any
secrets but you have an idea where he is
No
you don't know how you define g.od yeah
if there's a gun I'll catch you
Wow put you in a big spot didn't I Lord
yeah I mean that's that's a lot you know
these guys are your urban terrorists
your everyday domestic thugs would best
say to you honey after you catch me God
talk to him that's her again you hear
the compassion oh yeah and I'd say knock
this one should say okay Big Daddy we'll
see and then every time the guy says
don't I get my talk or I knew this was
gonna happen or dawg do you have a
cigarette
yeah you could just get like oh god okay
you know this is gonna be hard to give
him anything but a Taser you still miss
her so much don't you oh yeah I miss her
though it gets it's eight months it
doesn't that's the worst part it just
seems like yesterday and they say time
heals all wounds no it don't know no
what do you miss most about that her
comments her touch or smell her
encouragement her I'm gonna hire a real
bounty hunter few who gets his guy for
teasing me her did we say the blessing
for we eat
[Applause]
she was kind of everything yeah I kind
of hate to admit that cuz I'm such a
macho macho man but she was the glue
that held my family together so now I
got to redo it and restate
we're all like kind of brawling right
now so let's say how is the family doing
well you know the boys are all good the
girls are all in tilt talk about the
girls well the girls are very upset
because the other girls I might be
looking at or I may say so dad they just
like you because you're Dog the Bounty
Hunter they don't like it because you're
Dwayne or dad so the boys are like dad
do you know if you love them if you like
them work for you whatever you decide
what the girls are like no way no
everybody's a Dracula and they got
across that's clear up the thing about
moon your longtime assistant
are you dating her were you dating her
no never
moon you know I'm very lonesome so moon
now here's what psychiatrists have told
me she was very accessible she was very
I'd have to say stories about Who I am
she knew Beth and she talked about Beth
constantly remember what Beth used to
tell us and of course I lit right up
when she'd say that I was like
infatuated with the dream and I realized
that when my shrink told me no that's
not good and then I you know moon said
of all men if I wanted to pick a man
there's nothing about you that I'd pick
cross her out you know and she's still
my friend she still works arene takes
care of the finances and the part like
that but you know I kind of embarrassed
her a little bit and I shouldn't have
but and dr. oz on dr. oz when you
proposed to her and dr. oz would you
actually ask hoon to marry you yes I
just think that don't hurt my feelings
Duff haha I think he's an amazing human
being but I've known him before he was
famous so to me he's my best friend you
know always be my best friend I don't
see myself thinking past that I swear on
my mama and
bet that was not rehearsed and you saw
dr. oz he was like oh my god
and I knew I was gonna do it way before
I done it and I said this will stop
these rumors guys we don't read the bad
comments you know he don't mean it where
girls read them all so she read all the
bad moon is this dog is finally over the
moon and I mean she it was killing her
so I thought I got her into this I got
to get her out of it so that put a 98%
stop and then I'm going in Denver I'm
coming out of the weight room and
there's TMZ I'm like what I thought you
guys are only in LA no dog Harvey's
ordered us here so I mean they're like
following not TMZ but other people are
falling moon around and you know of
course they got a tracker on her car and
watch you know she's doesn't live with
me anymore
because it was so far to drive in the
mornings to get there hour and a half
and I said just get moved in downstairs
so much stuff went crazy you know in our
work mind your world yes yes it's up to
us to put it to a stop so I finally put
it to a stop you proposed
so that moon would say no and end
everything well I absolutely did that
would stop everything and when I said it
right mm-hmm I'm like a loon angel
whatever I said will you marry me and
she's like and I'm like oh my god she's
gonna say yes then what am I gonna do
what I was I was freaked out I don't
know if might the cameras on me or dr.
oz and moon but I'm like oh man Jesus
name what am I gonna do she says yes
that already got a rig I don't know what
again because I was gonna get down on
one knee and make it look you know
doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo but I
thought this is right now and I was very
emotional and so when I said it I think
I was about ready to cry but I knew that
she would say no and once she said no
that did it and ninety-eight percent the
rumors went away the lies went away
mm-hmm
would you have dated her if she wanted a
date yeah yeah I think I would have
because it was accessible where I didn't
have to explain everything and right but
true love
you know the love that I'm looking for
you know she kind of got me mad she's my
friends probably man if I tell you but
she said no one will ever love you like
that
you better stop looking for that because
there's no woman alive that will ever
love you like that and I thought all
right
because of course when you lose a spouse
man or woman you're looking for that
again there's somebody that's got to I
said yeah
well somebody's got to I'll even pay him
oh I won't but you know so you look for
that and then for someone to tell you
that it kind of stopped me dead in my
tracks I'm like wow you know so she's
kind of cold-blooded I mean she knows
how to stop me and that's like direct
point fine mmm is there especially in
your life now no no special lady right
now but I I think you know it's almost
time where I could start I'm not
I can maybe go out with the girl and eat
and you know and date a little if that's
a day when you do how do you date today
I forgot so no sorry right don't know
the last thing I want to do is get out
there and date it's a lot yes a lot
these days yes going back to this case
what will it mean when you wrap this up
and how will it wrap up what has been an
incredible but also trying season when
you catch the biggest fish you've ever
caught fishing you know you don't stop
fishing once you catch it but you bring
in that big old trout or whatever you
like oh and you stuff him and you put
him on the wall mm-hmm and you talk
about it and you go I'm going after your
daddy so it's gonna be like that it's
gonna be a final and to a chapter in my
life but it's gonna open a new one
because believe it or not I don't mean
to say this I'm getting better I am
brother I am I don't know if it's my
drone Bethy saying he's why he's lying
she's lying but I'm getting better at
this I'm getting in Hawaii it's Akamai
I'm smarter about it so this is the new
dog this is the newest one and you
believe that some of that though is best
hell will there be another season
well the ratings were thank you God very
much you know our God was like so
gracious and I love WGN I've loved every
Network I work with I really love Annie
you know I just so many friends I had
there but I like going to networks that
ain't no accused like CBS I was on my
friend I was on Hawaii five-o and
they're like oh don't bring a little
appearance you know I was so proud but
the big ones are big I like to go where
they're not so big and then make them
big because of you dog this network did
this and because of you and Devin I and
I really like that yeah we had some
outrageous numbers thing thank God and
thank the fans I got some crazy fans bro
so you'll be back I met a girl that said
you are the worst at getting attention I
have ever met
all you want is attention and I'm like
yes I love it when you and I they say hi
to you and I like I love that I live for
that so I'm probably the most attention
warner in the in america but my fans
know how to do that i love that they do
and they've kind of wrapped you in their
arms a little bit this season haven't
they maybe I have helped prop you up
oh yeah it's unbelievable like I was
ready to give up you know and I got
calls in the middle of the night and how
you get my phone number
oh I don't know and then TMZ's like the
camera guys are like paparazzi do you
know they try to blind you so you'll
trip in front of her right that's where
the shades and then they're like shut
the cameras off a dog we all want to
tell you you know like few of them
together we love you brother we love
best so much and you're like wow this is
the paparazzi telling me this right so
they're like yeah that means a lot
people sticking up for you you want to
do another season yes sir you do not do
the best season I've ever had cuz know
it's coming she's not there to say it
don't do this don't do that
I just have to say watch this mama well
you add anybody new to the crew could
there be anybody you would add new to
the crew you know that's amazing because
there's a sign again from God through
you again maybe so there's a couple that
deserve it that I'm really looking at
and you have to look at their morality
of course in crime the criminal records
their loyalty their bravery you can't be
a [ __ ] bow down or don't work no you
cannot gotta be a knife you know so I
got a couple I'm really looking at right
now when we first started this you
talked about you just finished working
out and you were headed back home the
other day you've been committed to your
fitness yes sir I put back on 18 pounds
I'm doing sit-ups like crazy and I told
my sensei that they the more and more I
sit up the more and more my stomach gets
bigger and he's like well when you do
your biceps and you keep working them
out do they get bigger and I go yeah
giggles dull could do it so when he
sit-ups so but I'm legs feet every
single thing I have to be a lean mean
fighting machine I have to I don't have
a ready bar I have to give it there by
myself now I don't hear the cheer of
Beth I have to give it there now it just
depend on myself I've never had to do
that for many years you know I've looked
at her for like a word or baby did you
see that yes I did Big Daddy the last
show she did we were chasing that guy
and I made them cut it and just I have
just that she goes the guy was gone
right we got away for us wardriving of
drownings going 100% and all of a sudden
I go right then left he turned right he
turned left turn right and she goes oh
my god you were incredible hmm I just
lit right up so I have just that where I
play every night where she says oh my
god honey she can give me too many
compliments you know right if you could
tell her one thing what would you tell
her I love you and they will never be
another mrs. dog ever there could be
another mrs. this is but they'll never
be another mrs. dog and I still have a
lot of score I still have
it's half time what are you gonna do for
Valentine's Day I was gonna be a recluse
but I don't really you stunned me I
don't know is it a hard day kind if you
think about it you know what are they
doing up there yeah they're Valentimes
nothing compared to mine you talk about
that if you were getting sick or you got
shot or you got hurt or something like
that that you would be okay with it cuz
you could go see Beth yes well I've
always had not uh sorry I've always had
not a fear to die but I've been cautious
I didn't want to I still don't want to
but I'm not afraid to I'm thinking that
all of a sudden I'll hear bow-bow and
she'll be like wow what took you so long
Big Daddy well there's two things that
happen you either die and forget it all
or there's a heaven right now you so
many people are like oh there's a heaven
for sure dog white you've been there
come on you know we don't know and it's
not bad not to know mm-hmm
so I don't know but I hope there is if
not then you're do you forget it all
died forget it all right right but if
it's true then there's a heaven then I'm
ready because I've not every night asked
the Lord to forgive me for the sins as
David did he said forgive me for the
sins I don't even know I'd committed
mm-hmm so I'm like Lord forgive me for
the sins I don't know I committed and
you know I would be ready if it happened
if I go I want a private funeral so that
it doesn't overtake hers she'd be so mad
you know she 35 million hits remember we
talked right 35 million crazy thousands
hundreds of thousands watched her send
off minds private cuz I don't want to
blow her record she's mad at me but if
it happens
I had a stock to leave it today the
songs he's like dad shut up I don't want
to hear that son you're the one hears
the songs I want here's what I want and
here's how I want it so you've already
laid out how it should be in case
something happens to you yes I've never
done that my life
because I believe the Bible says the
power of life and death are in the
tongue the hardest part of the body to
control is not what we think it's the
tongue right for God said let there be
light and there was so I have never
planned that because I was afraid now
I'm planning it do they call it a will
you in LA yeah have you quit smoking
I've down to less than a pack a day you
can smell right I'm trying on the patch
boy it is tough but I'm doing it I was
wondering what am I going to do it my
hands you know I can't be able to do
this what's gonna happen I sleep better
I breathe better
I work out better man the cigarettes it
should be listed as a dangerous drug at
least a second count dangerous drug yeah
no because they are not good how long do
you think before you can kick this habit
totally well Leland was of course my son
my third son is smoked for years and yes
took him about a year with the nicotine
gum and all that and then today I said
son you want on the airplane son you
want one of these nicotine patches like
that I don't do that no more
like whoa good job son so it took him
about a year so I would think six months
to a year what do you do next you write
a book you have a TV show what do you do
well of course that I've done a couple
books and got lucky and so they're you
know we're negotiating and it's called I
believe they've named it life without
Beth mm-hmm and I just I'm a grandpa and
I said I'm just a bounty hunter
that's all that's what I'm gonna just
keep doing I just I'm not done I'm ready
once you find out that it's an incurable
lung cancer there's no stage five
explain to folks what life without Beth
this well life without Beth was you know
in the morning with me pill night we
went to bed food every single thing I
did was either with her because of her
or with her yeah so now she's not there
so things are complete taste the food
everything has completely changed I was
the compassionate one the truth I don't
want to lie she's meeting his
rattlesnake but so I got to kind of be
the mom and the dad now you know I gotta
get in the corner I love you
you know used to be I'd be like mom's
upset don't worry I love you don't worry
get the corner son daughter but now it's
like you have to be both so it's a whole
different thing thank I thank God that I
had her I would if I wouldn't matter
there would be no dog there would be no
dog so I had her I feel so lucky to have
her now I have to make her proud and
making her proud as catching this bad
guy yes this one's about
she's my everything
[Music]